thank you mr speaker
with with permission i will make a
statement
i'm grateful to sue gray for her reports
today and i want to thank her for the
work that she's done
i also thank the metropolitan police for
completing their investigation
and i want to begin today by renewing my
apology to the house to the whole
country for
the short lunch time gathering on the
19th of june 2020 in the cabinet room
during which i stood at my place at the
cabinet table in which i received a
fixed penalty notice and i also want to
say mr speaker above all that i take
full responsibility for everything that
took place on my watch sue gray's report
has emphasized that it is up to the
political leadership in number 10 to
take ultimate responsibility and of
course i do
but since these investigations have now
come to an end this is my first
opportunity
to set out some of the context
and to explain both my understanding of
what happened and also to explain what i
have previously said to this house and
it's it's important to set out
that
over a period of about
600 days
gatherings on a total of eight dates
have been found to be in breach of the
regulations in a building that is 5 300
meters square across five floors
excluding the flats
mr speaker i do think it is impossible
it is important because this is the
first time i've had a chance i've had to
set out the context
hundreds of staff are entitled to work
and in the cabinet office which has
thousands of officials and now is the
biggest it's been in any point in its
hundred year history that is itself one
of the reasons why the government is
look now looking for change and reform
mr speaker those staff working in
downing street were permitted to
continue attending their office for the
purpose of work
and the exemption under the regulations
applied to their work because of the
nature of their jobs reporting directly
to the prime minister
these people were working extremely long
hours
doing their best to give this country
the ability to fight the pandemic
jury mr speaker i appreciate that this
is no uh mitigation but it is important
to set up the prime minister please just
just one sec can i just appeal to the
house expect it to be heard and i want
everybody to hear it and i want the same
respect to be shown to the leader of the
opposition afterwards so please this is
a very very important statement the
country wants to hear as well prime
minister
yeah mr speaker i'm trying to set out
the context not to uh not to to mitigate
or uh to absorb myself in any way
the exemption on which they were present
in downing street includes
those circumstances where officials and
advisors were leaving the government
and it was
appropriate
to
recognize them to thank them for the
work that they've done
[Music]
let me let me come to that mr speaker i
briefly attended such gatherings to
thank them for their service
which i believe is one of the essential
duties of leadership and particularly
important
and particularly important when people
need to feel that their contributions
have been appreciated
and to keep morale as high as possible
i'm trying to explain the reasons i was
there mr speaker
and it's clear from what uh sue gray has
had to say
that some of these gatherings
then went on
far longer than was necessary
and they were clearly
in breach of the rules and they fell
foul of the rules
i have to tell the house because the
house will need to know this and again
this is not to mitigate or to extenuate
i had no knowledge of those subsequent
proceedings because i simply wasn't
there
and i have been as surprised and
disappointed
as anyone else in this house
as the revelations have unfolded
and frankly mr speaker i have been
appalled
by some of the behavior
particularly in the treatment of the
security and the cleaning staff
and i would like to apologize
to those members of staff and i expect
anyone who behaved in that way to
apologize to them as well
and
i'm happy to set on the record now
that when i said i came to this house
and said in all sincerity that the rules
and guidance have been followed
at all times it was what i believed to
be true
it was certainly the case
when i was present at gatherings to wish
staff
farewell
and the house will note that my
attendance at these moments
brief as it was
has not been found to be outside the
rules
but clearly this was not the case for
some of those gatherings after i have
left and at other gatherings when i was
not even in the building
so i would like to correct
i would like to correct
the record uh to take this opportunity
not in any sense to absolve myself of
responsibility
which i take and have always taken
but simply
simply to explain
why i spoke as i did in this house
mr speaker
in response to her interim
report sugree acknowledges that very
significant changes have already been
enacted
she writes
and i quote
i am pleased that progress is being made
in addressing the issues i raised
and she adds
since my update there have been changes
to the organization and management of
downing street in the cabinet office
with the aim of creating clearer lines
of leadership and accountability and now
these need the chance and time to bed in
number 10 now has its own permanent
secretary charged with applying the
highest standards of governance there
are now easier ways for staff to voice
any worries
and sue welcomes that sue grey welcomes
that and i quote steps have since been
taken
to introduce more easily accessible
means by which to raise concerns
electronically in person or online
including directly with the permanent
secretary
the entire senior management has changed
there is a new
there is a new
there is a new chief of staff
an elected member of this house who also
commands the status of a cabinet
minister
there is a new director of
communications a new principal private
secretary and another of other key
appointments
in
my office
i am confident with the
changes and new structures
that are now in place
that we are humbled
by the experience
and we have learned our lesson
and i want to conclude
by saying that
i mr speaker i i'm humbled and i have
learned a lesson
and i want to and i want to conclude by
saying that whatever the failings
whatever the failings of
yeah will come to that we'll come to
that
and whatever the failings of
number 10 and the cabinet office
throughout this very difficult period
which and my own which i take full
responsibility
i continue to believe that the civil
servants and advisers in question
hundreds of them
thousands of them some of whom mr
speaker the very people who've received
fines
are good hard-working people
motivated motivated by the highest
calling to do the very best for our
country and i will always be proud of
what they achieved
including procuring essential
life-saving ppe creating the biggest
testing program in europe and helping to
enable the development and distribution
of the vaccine which got this country
through the worst pandemic of a century
and now mr speaker we must get our
country through the aftershocks of covid
with every ounce of ingenuity and
compassion and and hard work
so i hope that today as well as learning
the lessons
from
the su grades report which i'm glad i
commissioned and again i repeat my i'm
glad i'm grateful to her
i i hope very much but now that she has
reported
we will be able to move on
and focus
on the on the priorities of the british
people
standing firm against russian aggression
easing the hardship caused by the rising
costs the people are facing fulfilling
our pledges to generate a high-wage
high-skill high employment economy that
will unite and level up across the whole
of our united kingdom that is my mission
that is our mission that is the mission
of the whole of the government and we
will work day and night to deliver it
and i commend this statement to the
house
we don't come to the leader of the
opposition kyostama
thank you mr speaker
the door of number 10 downing street is
one of the great symbols of our
democracy
those who live behind it exercise great
power
but they do so knowing their stay is
temporary
long after they've gone that door and
the democracy it represents
will remain firm and unyielding
but britain's constitution is fragile
it relies on members of this house and
the custodians of number 10 behaving
responsibly honestly and in the interest
of the british people
when our leaders fall short of these
standards this house
has to adapt
for months members opposite have asked
the country to wait first for the police
investigation which concluded
that this prime minister is the first in
our country's history to have broken the
law in office
then they asked the country to wait for
the sue grey report
they need weight no longer
that report lays bare the rot that under
this prime minister has spread in number
10
and it provides definitive proof
of how those within the building
treated the sacrifices of the british
people
with utter contempt
[Applause]
when the dust settles and the anger
subsides
this report will stand as a monument to
the hubris and the arrogance of a
government
that believed it was run wool for them
and another rule for everyone else
[Music]
the details are stark
five months ago the prime minister told
this house all guidance was completely
followed in number 10.
yet we now know he attended events on
the 17th of december
at least one of those attending has
received a fine for it deeming it
illegal we know that on the 18th of
december an event was held in which
staff drank excessively which others in
the building described as a party and
the cleaners were left to mop up the red
wine the next day
on the 20th of may
as a covert press conference was taking
place
one of his senior officials was told be
mindful
cameras are leaving don't walk about
waving bottles
it is now impossible to defend the prime
minister's words to this house
this is about trust
because during that may 20 press
conference the british public were told
normal life as we know it is a long way
off
but that wasn't the case in number 10.
[Music]
even now after 126 fines
they think it's everyone else's fault
but theirs
they expect others to take the blame
whilst they cling on
they pretend that the prime minister has
somehow been exonerated
as if the fact that he only broke the
law once is worthy of praise
the truth is they set the bar for his
conduct
lower than a snake's belly
and now they expect the rest of us to
congratulate him as he stumbles over it
number 10 symbolizes the principles of
public life in this country selflessness
integrity objectivity accountability
openness
honesty
leadership
but who could read this report and
honestly believe the prime minister has
upheld those standards
the reason the british public have had
to endure this pass was his refusal to
admit the truth
or do the decent thing when he was found
to have broken the law
this report was necessary
because of what sue grey describes as
failures of leadership and judgment
for which senior political leadership
must bear responsibility
it is that failure of leadership that
has now left his government paralyzed
in the middle of a cost of living crisis
the government has turned the focus of
his government
to saving his own skin
it's utterly shameful
it is precisely because he cannot lead
but it falls to others to do so
i've been clear
what leadership looks like
[Applause]
i haven't broken any rules
and any attempt
any attempt to complain
sorry
can i just
calm it down quite rightly i wanted to
the prime minister i expect the same of
the leader of the opposition now those
who don't mistake you please go and have
a cup of tea or something
i've been clear what leadership looks
like
i haven't broken any rules and any
attempt to compare a perfectly legal
takeaway while working to this catalogue
of criminality looks even more
ridiculous today
but mr speaker
if the police decide otherwise
i will do the decent thing
and step down
the public need to know that not all
politicians are the same
that not all politicians put themselves
above their country
that honesty integrity and
accountability matter
members on the opposite benches now also
need to show leadership
[Music]
this prime minister is steering the
country in the wrong direction
they can hide in the backseat eyes
covered praying for a miracle
or they can act
stop this out of touch out control prime
minister from driving britain towards
disaster
we waited for the sugray report
the country can't wait any longer the
value symbolized by the door of number
10 must be restored
members opposite must finally do their
bit
they must tell the current inhabitant
their leader
that this has gone on too long
the game is up
you cannot be a lawmaker and a law
breaker
and it's it's time to pack his bags
only then can the government function
again
only then can the rot be carved out
only then can we restore the dignity of
that great office
and the democracy that it represents yes
prime minister uh mr speaker the right
honourable gentleman talks about uh what
went on in
number 10 dining street and the uh the
events
behind that that black door
and uh the number of the events and and
and i will say to him is that
he uh throughout the pandemic was not
uh leading many thousands of people in
the fight against coronavirus uh he was
sniping from the sidelines and veering
from one position to the next
and and today mr speaker he's he's done
it again week after week week after week
he could have come to this house and
talked about the economy about uh
ukraine uh about the cost of living no
mr speaker time after time uh he he he
chose to focus on this issue uh he could
have he could have recorded he could
have shown some
some common sense mr speaker and
recognized
that when people are working very hard
together
day in day out
that it can be difficult to draw the
boundary mr speaker between work and
socializing
and yet after months of his
frankly sanctimonious obsession
uh mr speaker the great gaseous zeppelin
of his pomposity has been permanently
punctured uh and irretrievably by the
revelation that he is himself what he
didn't mention this he is himself under
investigation by the police
but by the police mr speaker
and yet and i'm you know i'm not going
to mince my words i've got to say this
sir corma mr speaker
is currently failing to hold himself to
the same high standards that he demanded
of me
he it's true he called for me to resign
mr speaker when the when the
investigation
began
why
why is he in his place
[Applause]
mr holden
it's the second time please help me to
help you because i'm sure you want to
hear the rest of the prime minister
mr speaker mr speaker mr speaker he
should he should at least be he should
at least be consistent and hold himself
uh to the same standards uh he's
he's still there and so is the uh the
shadow deputy leader and mr speaker i
apologize when the revelations emerged i
i continue to apologize i repeat that i
am humbled by what has happened and we
have instituted profound changes
throughout number 10. but i think in
view of the mess that he has found
himself in himself uh he would it would
now be a sensible thing for him to uh to
apologize so that we can all
so that we can all collectively move on
mr speaker and that i think is what the
people of this country want to see above
all they want to see leadership from
this house of commons leadership from
both parties mr speaker in dealing with
their priorities and that is why we are
focused on getting through the
aftershocks of kovid and that's why i'm
proud of what we did to
roll out the fastest uh vaccine campaign
in europe and that's why i'm proud that
we now have the lowest unemployment
anywhere uh in this country for 50 years
mr speaker that is what the people of
this country want uh i i appreciate uh
that uh he has his points to make but i
think overwhelmingly the will of this
country is for us now to say thank you
to say thank you to sue gray and for us
collectively to move on
sir robert butland you mr
speaker
my right honourable friend well knows
the rules apply to him as much to all of
us and the rules of this house are clear
that anybody who comes here and
deliberately lies and misleads this
house
should leave their position resign or
apologize my right honourable friend has
been asked many times about specific
incident specific events that sue gray
has outlined
did has he on any occasion
come to this house in response to
specific questions about specific events
and deliberately lied to us
no mr speaker for the reason for the
reason i have given that
at the time that i uh spoke to this
house i believe that what i was uh was
doing was was to attend work events and
uh with the exception of the event in
the
in the cabinet room uh that is a a view
that has been vindicated uh by the
investigation
we now come to the leader of the smp in
blackford aye thank you mr speaker as i
speak the public is pouring over the
sordid details of what went on out of
the public eye behind the high gates and
the walls of the prime minister's
residence and the report is damning
it concludes
many gatherings and many individuals did
not adhere to covert guidance
events were attended by leaders in
government
and should not have been allowed to
happen
junior civil servants believed that
involvement was permitted by the
attendance of senior leaders
there was an unacceptable lack of
respect
and poor treatment of security and
cleaning staff and crucially mr speaker
the senior leadership at the center
both political and official
must bear responsibility
for this culture
that leadership
came from the top
and the prime minister
in the words of the report
must bear responsibility for the culture
a fish rots
from the head
mr speaker
the prime minister's dispatch box denial
of a party taking place in the 13th of
november
is now proven to be untrue
he was there on the 13th of november
photographed raising a toast
surrounded by gin wine and other
revelers
the charge of misleading parliament
is a resignation matter
well the prime minister now finally
resigned
yeah yeah this prime minister has
adopted a systematic concerted and
sinister pattern of evasion
truthfulness
honesty
and transparency do not enter his
vocabulary
it is just not part of his way of being
and it speaks for the type of man that
he is
credibility
truth
morality
all matter
and the prime minister
has been found lacking time and time
again and you can shake his head
but that's the reality prime minister
ethics have to be part of our public
life
and ethical behavior
has to be at the core of the demeanor
and the response of any prime minister
the prime minister
brings shame on the office and has
displayed contempt
not only to the members of this house
but to every single person who followed
the rules they stayed away from family
those who missed funerals
those who lost someone they loved
so when the tory members opposite retire
to the 1922 committee this evening
i hope they will bear in mind
the now infamous government advert
featuring a desperately ill
covered patient
it said
look into her eyes
and tell her
you never
bend the rules
if they don't submit a letter
if they don't remove this prime minister
how will they ever ever look at their
constituents in the eye ever again
[Applause]
mr speaker i think that uh the right
honourable gentleman should uh look at
closely at her at sue grey's report and
i repeat my thanks to her uh i
stress that the nature and uh and length
of my involvement in the uh in these
events is very clear from what she says
and i take full responsibility uh for
what happened and uh and that is why
we've taken the the steps that we have
to inform and improve the way number 10
works uh we're we are we are humbled uh
by what has happened and we have changed
it
peterborough
thank you mr speaker um since i've been
elected to this house i've been running
a campaign called listening to
wellington rushton
and you may recall on one occasion that
group
asked me to present a letter at pmq
calling for a previous prime minister to
resign what they're telling me today mr
speaker
is their concerns are the terrible war
in ukraine
the illegal immigrants crossing the
channel
and the economy and their message to the
prime minister
is to get on with the job yeah does he
agree with the listening to wellington
rushton campaign
i i agree with him i agree with him uh
profoundly and passionately mr speaker
and that's exactly what i'm gonna do
catherine west
thank you very much mr speaker the prime
minister said that on the 13th of
november 2020 the abba party he attended
briefly his defense was a job interview
can he confirm he was only in his flat
and he met henry newman to discuss a job
and can he confirm what the other
special advisers were doing
were they part of the job interview as
well
mr speaker
that uh evening was uh extensively
investigated uh to the best of my
knowledge and i don't i i i don't
believe i can improve on what sue grey
has had to say
tobias
thank you mr speaker this is a
damning report about the absence of
leadership focus and discipline in
number 10 the one place where you expect
to find those attributes in abundance
i made my point my position very clear
to the prime minister he does not have
my support but a question i humbly put
to my colleagues is are you willing
day in and day out to defend this
behavior publicly
can we continue to govern without
distraction given the erosion of the
trust with the british people and can we
win the general election on this current
trajectory the question i place to the
prime ministers now
mr speaker i'm being heckled by my own
people if we cannot work out what we're
going to do
then the broad church of the
conservative party will lose the next
general election but my question to the
prime minister is very clear on the
question of leadership
can he think of any other prime minister
who'd have allowed such a culture of
indiscipline to take place under their
watch and if it did
would they not have resigned
mr speaker i think to answer the
question that he uh put to uh all of us
on these benches i think the answer is
overwhelm overwhelmingly and
emphatically yes uh we are going to go
on uh win the next general election
because we're going to get on with the
job mr speaker
ed david mr speaker the prime minister
says he's sorry
but he's only sorry he got caught
he didn't care then
as he parted during lockdown
when people couldn't see their dying
loved ones
he didn't care last year
when he insisted that no rules had been
broken
and he doesn't care now
when families across our country are
struggling to heat their homes fill
their cars and put feed on the table
with a cost of living crisis that has
only deepened while the prime minister
been scrambling to save his own skin
so mr speaker
can the prime minister look the british
people in the eye
and name one person
just one person
he cares about
more than himself
mr speaker i can tell him that there are
uh people in uh number 10 dining street
including me
who cared passionately about making sure
that we had the ppe that we needed we
had the fastest a vaccine rollout uh in
europe and then we protected this
country from covered and that is what
people were doing and i i may say that
the abuse that has been directed at uh
civil servants and officials uh is i
think wholly unwarranted
robert
thank you mr speaker when i think of
civil servants and advisors during that
period i think of the brilliant civil
servants
who helped move mountains to create the
shielding program within a matter of
days
i think of the brilliant civil servants
and advisors that got 90 of homeless
people off the streets within days
would my right or friend agree with me
that these achievements and others
should mean that nothing in this report
is a stain upon the character of the
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of civil servants whether in number 10
other government departments or across
the country who helped steer this
country through the pandemic and
secondly
difficult though this is to say for many
with a a war in europe
with an economic crisis
with the challenges this country faces
is it not really true
that it is now time to turn a page
and for this country
our politics and this house to move
forward
i i agree with him absolutely uh
passionately mr speaker i think the best
thing uh i think we can study the uh the
report we can uh draw the conclusions
that we want the best thing now for our
country is to move forward together and
that's what we're going to do
dave angela riedel
uh mr speaker
we all understand and the prime minister
understands that not being truthful on
the floor of this house
requires a resignation
my honorable friend the member for
hornsey and wood green asked the prime
minister a point-blank
question on the floor of this house when
he was at that dispatch box she asked
him if he had been
to a party on the 13th of november in 10
downing street
he said he hadn't and that no party had
happened
there are four pictures of it
there are four pictures of it
um
mr speaker in featured in the su grey
report will the prime minister account
now
on the floor of the house for his answer
to that very specific question
yes of course mr speaker i tried to do
it in what i said earlier
on and the answer is that i
it's part of my job to say thank you to
people who work in government that's
what i was doing i believed it was a
work event and indeed uh there has been
no fine issue to me as a result of my
attendance at that event because that is
what i was doing thank you
mr speaker i commend to gray for the
report and i do understand why people
are angry having looked at the pictures
of the birthday party in the cabinet
office i think the opposition are going
to be quite hard pressed to explain why
they have such moral outrage about that
but not about the late night beers that
happened
however
however
one of the things i was very troubled by
was the language that was used towards
the custodian would the prime minister
join it with me now and i'm sure the
whole house would agree
the level of respect and gratitude that
we have to every single cleaner and
worker and
all the people in the tea room that work
in this place thank you
i thank her very very much and i agree
uh very much with what she has just said
and i think that the uh as i said in my
opening statement mr speaker i think the
behavior towards uh custer any any
rudeness uh towards a member of staff is
absolutely inexcusable and i want
whoever uh was responsible uh to
apologize
don't you sing dancing thank you very
much mr speaker i feel as if i've
completely let down those who showered
me with so much love
why wasn't i by the bedside of my lovely
grandmother during her final few days
why did i let her die alone in that
hospital why did i not attend the
funeral of my uncle
because of worries about government
restrictions on numbers and why did i
not go to comfort my brother-in-law's
father
as he was dying in a slough care home
why
with all of this context
it is utterly
hypocritical for those individuals
who were preaching to us ad nauseum
about patriotism the flag and the queen
for those very people to then be having
late night parties including two on the
night before the queen had to sit all
alone during her husband's funeral when
the country was in a state of national
mourning absolutely shameless
surprise prime minister given that the
prime minister is not going to do the
right and honorable thing
does he agree with me that it is not the
support and sympathy of the british
people that is keeping him in power the
majority of whom want him to resign is
the support and sympathy of those
concerns
order order
i'm sorry but it's meant to be a
question and also we don't normally
bring monica into proceedings
and i'm sure that the primes will have
got the gist and quite really i
understand the emotions behind it but
it's going to be shorter prime minister
mr speaker i'm i'm very sorry for the
right of the honourable gentleman's loss
uh and he has a perfect right to speak
with a uh with a passion that he uh that
he does uh all i can say is that uh we
are we i take full responsibility for
what happened i i do and and we have we
have made extensive extensive changes
john barron
uh mr speaker i believe both leaders
have a lot to answer for um with regards
to this issue
the british army teaches you or
certainly believes that it's very core
that you serve to lead
and you lead by example
given the extent of rule breaking in
number 10 does my right honourable
friend
believe that what he has said to the
house since about there being no rule
breaking
past the test of reasonableness
i i think he's he's putting he's asking
exactly the right question and i
understand why he asks it uh but i i
i've tried to give my answer uh to to
him and to the and to the house which is
that uh i believe that i was attending
uh work events those are the ones which
i had uh knowledge and uh with the
exception of what took place in the the
cabinet room in uh in june
of
2020 uh uh that that view has been
sustained by the investigation janet
sharon
speaker neither i nor my edinburgh
southwest constituents we'd wish to live
in a state where the government of the
day could influence the police in the
exercise of their duty to investigate
without fear or favor
so we're puzzled as to why the prime
minister didn't receive questionnaires
in respect of three gatherings where
other people in number 10 received
questionnaires and were also puzzled as
to why the abba party in the prime
minister's flat has never been
investigated either by sue gray
or the metropolitan police
so can i ask the prime minister
what can be done by way of an
independent investigation
to assure me and my constituents that
the metropolitan police have not been
nobbled ah
well that would that would greatly
surprise me mr speaker but i think she
should uh look more closely at sue
gray's report because i think she will
find the answer she needs
michael fabrico mr speaker i understand
the outrage of people in litchfield and
burntwood and indeed the honorable
gentleman opposite who have lost loved
ones but i also understand having been
an employer that attending an event
where someone is leaving is considered
to be
a working event
and my right honourable friend clearly
got guidance that turned out to be wrong
so can he now explain how the
appointment of a new permanent secretary
at number 10 will make a difference in
the future
i i i thank him uh very much and what
we're doing is not only of the
the structure of number 10 has changed
so there's more uh
direct uh command and control for the
whole building which was which was a
little bit unclear before and so there
is a new permanent secretary with direct
responsibility for the whole office as
it were hundreds and hundreds of people
uh as opposed to that uh function being
nominally to be addressed by the
principal private secretary uh and and
uh the lines of as sue said sue gray
said uh the lines of command and the
lines of command uh were not
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker
after months of shuffling around
prevarication
and book passing
this report makes it absolutely clear
that when the british public were taking
those restrictions seriously
the prime minister was taking the
british public
for fools
that's why the prime minister and his
government
cannot now
be taken seriously
isn't it time he said goodbye so that
the rest of us could say good riddance
mr speaker i really don't think that the
um government can be blamed for the for
the delay that he complains of uh it
took a long time for the uh the met to
do their work it was exhaustive and i i
don't believe that it sustains the
conclusion uh that he is drawn uh not at
all
thank you mr speaker mr speaker when i
asked the prime minister about sugray's
interim findings on the 31st of january
he asked me to wait for the inquiry
report he asked many members that day to
do the same thing subsequently he has
asked the media to wait for the findings
of the report and he knows that many
colleagues on these benches have told
their constituents they're waiting for
the inquiry report so i was very
surprised to read in the times the
information that he may have asked sue
gray not to publish the report at all
is there any truth to that suggestion
prime minister
mr speaker what uh
sue gray has published is entirely
for sukrey
and uh and she it is a holy independent
uh report mr speaker
mr speaker the last time i asked the
prime minister a question on this
subject
i said the problem with him and i've got
on with him over the years is he is a
serial offender
and even serial offenders if they
actually confess that they've done wrong
and then repent for what they've done
they can be actually be forgiven because
they're mending their ways
i'm sorry mr speaker but today's
performance from the prime minister
shows no real remorse of trying to shift
back on other people and i believe now
with all the many faces i see on the
other side that he should now resign
mr speaker i i've apologized and i
am as i have said deeply contrite about
what happens i take responsibility
we are affecting and have done a huge
amount of change already in number 10
but i i it is my judgment that the best
thing
for the country is now to move on uh
from this issue and to learn the lessons
dr julian lewis given the cavalier way
in which these rules were interpreted in
number 10
does my right honorable friend agree
that rules of such intrusiveness and
rigidity must never again be imposed on
the british people as a whole
[Applause]
well mr speaker we were dealing with a
pandemic that was absolutely
unprecedented and we did not uh we did
not have any uh immediate tools to
control it short of a vaccine without
asking people uh to restrict their
behavior i'm sure there are plenty of
lessons we can learn from the future
about how to do it better and i'm sure
that would be a matter for the inquiry
angus brendan mcneil thank you very much
mr speaker why he is still unwittingly a
great asset for scottish independence
the question everywhere however is how
to goodness is he still prime minister
of this current united kingdom
well uh mr speaker i think the uh the
answer to that question is contained in
the uh the continued uh support of the
people of the united kingdom for
our union uh and and uh despite
everything that they uh are doing to try
to overturn the democratic verdict of
2014 i don't believe that they will
succeed
natalie outfit
thank you mr speaker um i thank my right
honourable friend for his further
apology and his explanation today which
is important for many of my constituents
does he note paragraph 4 page 36 of the
subgrey report that says there have been
changes to the organization and
management of downing street in the
cabinet office with the aim of creating
clear alliance of leadership and
accountability and does he agree with
her that these changes need to bed in
and that the focus of our government
must be laser-like in tackling the cost
of living crisis that has come about as
a result of the covert pandemic and
ukraine and that this is the concern
over and above everything else of my
constituents
well mr speaker
the general opposition says that
answered i i will i i i agree uh i agree
completely what she uh what she has just
said and that's why we're gonna get on
with the job
chris brown thank you mr speaker what a
load of bologna so boris johnson uh
asking answering questions in at the
house of commons following the sugree
report let's listen to chris bryant
the truth is the prime minister
encouraged the gatherings he attended
the gatherings he poured the drinks at
the gatherings and he even raised the
toast at the gathering so he knew
perfectly well that these gatherings had
taken place and the most despicable
thing of all
is that sue gray says
she saw multiple examples of a lack of
respect and poor treatment of security
and cleaning staff because they knew
what the rules meant even if nobody else
does
does he show no contrition no sense of
shame
that downing street under him has been a
cesspit full of arrogant entitled
narcissists
[Applause]
[Music]
mr speaker as i've said uh to the house
already i think that it is absolutely
disgraceful in any circumstances uh to
be rude uh to people uh who are helping
you and rude to uh to staff rude to
custodians it's intolerable uh and i
will make sure that uh those who are
guilty of it uh apologize or are
otherwise disciplined
jack barrett
mr speaker now
well we were just stepping away for a
moment from that chris brown giving
quite a strong uh response to the prime
minister there um so the prime minister
is answering questions about the sue
grey report he made a statement to the
house uh our political editor beth rugby
is here with me beth let's just i
suppose quickly just remind ourselves
what the key findings of the secret
report are well i think the key findings
if you bought this 37 page report down
is that senior leadership must bear
responsibility
for behaviors that will dismay many
and she also said uh that uh junior
members of staff
felt compelled at times to have to go to
events i think within the report
uh within the report you have a
catalogue of different parties law
breaking parties you have lured details
of drunkenness minor altercations people
rolling out on a couple of different
events at three or four in the morning
at a time when the rest of the country
was on in lockdown so it's embarrassing
it's damming of the culture of
government what's interesting within sue
gray's report is she says she doesn't
believe it was the prevailing culture of
government and the civil service and the
unspoken implication of that is she
believes it was a culture that existed
specifically under boris johnson i think
that's mean and i take
from that uh just in terms of
where it leaves the prime minister i
think it's fair to say that in terms of
the report it shows senior staff
with premeditation of events
acknowledgement of getting away with it
i mean martin reynolds his former
private sector said we got away with it
referring to the may 23 event but
there's no actual smoking done of the
prime minister
at one of these events late into the
night drinking etc and his defense you
heard it in the commons there was that
these events went awry after he left and
he was working
i think that's his defense
in terms of what's just happened in the
commons i think the prime minister is
trying to stress there that
the apology is there again he says the
entire management has changed uh but i
think what's also clear is that apart
from the two people at the top the
cabinet secretary simon case is still
there and the prime minister is still
there so when sue gray says the
leadership politically and officially
must take responsibility it doesn't mean
the top two leaders although he was
pressed on that uh where does it where
does it leave him with mps i think
there's a couple of things
one mp has just messaged me and said
it's interesting how few colleagues are
willing to go on the benches today and
defend him publicly
you saw that tobias ellwood who has
publicly called for the prime minister's
uh resignation of former minister chair
of the
select committee uh
called the prime minister out he said to
colleagues how can you keep defending
this behavior warned that they would
lose the next election under johnson you
said to the prime minister would another
prime minister entertain this behavior
and not resign but the pm is facing it
down you can see from his response that
he genuinely thinks that these work
events he thinks he's been vindicated by
the fact he hasn't had penalty notices
and the acid test really is what do his
mps do now it's up to them whether they
try to force a vote of confidence in him
or not but in terms of the report do i
think there's been a material moment in
this report that has changed the
prospects for him i think everything
that's been revealed here is kind of
what we already knew
uh
apart from the details and also some of
the the the actual text messages with
the senior civil staff i mean behavior
meditation behavior towards cleaning and
behavior towards staff which is awful
yeah
right well let's return to uh the uh
house of commons just let you know also
a timetable for the afternoon um at
about 3 30 the prime minister is going
to make a press statement um so
uh that will happen at 3 30 this
afternoon i'll bring you that live of
course but for now let's return to the
house of commons
mr speaker i don't believe that the
prime minister has any credibility left
because my constituents tell me that
they don't believe what he says so i
want to ask the prime minister about
what i think to be the bare minimum in
this situation
when it comes to the cleaning staff and
the security staff in number 10 treated
with a lack of respect
has the prime minister personally
apologized to them
i i thank her this is the first that
i've seen of the uh of the uh
uh detailed uh criticisms of of of of
civil servants for that abuse i've said
that i think it's in intolerable and
and i will make sure that uh staff
custodians cleaners uh who were treated
disrespectfully uh get get a proper
apology i i've apologized to to them
today
she may i've apologized them today
already uh from mr spatchbox
really in my 21 years of this household
i have such utter drivel in what we've
been presenting today i've tried to find
words to
capture what the prime minister said
disingenuous delusional slippery
self-serving i know i can't see this one
is in this place no attempt at remorse
all somebody else's fault surely if he
was half the man that he thinks he is he
would summon that self-respect and just
go yeah
i want to quote the following to the
prime minister and all those on his side
we've just heard one who want to suggest
the kobe rules didn't matter
it's from palliative care doctor dr
rachel clark
to nhs staff it was abundantly clear
that the way you survive a pandemic is
together
in 2020 collective compliance was all
nhs patients had to protect them
basic selfless public decency mattered
rules were hated but obeyed because we
care about each other
and that glass of wine in the pm's hand
is being thrown in the face of all of us
how does he reply to that
[Applause]
mr speaker i
wish things could have been handled
better and i wish things had uh uh had
we got things right in number 10 in the
way that uh we didn't and i apologize
again for uh for things that got wrong
uh but the things we got wrong uh but uh
we've already changed uh the uh the way
we work and uh i really think it's time
that the country moved on
by the
chamberlain the prime minister's
previously stated that partygate
investigations would be fully complied
with but today there are reports that
senior staff simply didn't answer the
questionnaires and as a result have
avoided being fined can the prime
minister therefore confirm whether all
senior staff at number 10 including
himself met their obligations and
replied to the metropolitan police and
fool yeah
as she knows those are a matter for the
met
oh you're going fast
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
said i briefly attended such governments
to thank them for their service which i
believe is one of the essential duties
of leadership he wouldn't need no
leadership if it hit him in the first
thing i have my constituents done i'll
tell him why because there's doctors who
gave their lives their families weren't
allowed to attend their funerals i was
on the phone and my
the trust that i live it i worked with
had to make decisions of leadership to
separate people from not being able to
see their dying relatives i was on the
phone to somebody whilst they died
begging me to let them see him that's
what leadership is when those were
difficult decisions they had to make
when nurses couldn't go home and had to
book into hotels so they didn't spread
infections so where is if he had an
ounce of leadership he'd resign so why
doesn't he yeah
i refer to what i've already said
i don't care about those people
mr speaker
the prime minister's credibility is like
a slow puncture
he reinflates it occasionally but isn't
the truth his party needs a new front
wheel
mr speaker i think they really need to
ask a more uh a new question
i have to say i'm absolutely appalled by
the behavior of some members in this
chamber today
they're refusing to accept
responsibility
they're cheering cheering and saying
let's move on what can i tell you prime
minister there's a young man in black
one who can't move on
because due to a war on his head
rather than an appointment with a doctor
who was asked to send in a picture
three months later he was actually told
a stage four cancer
so the impact
is widespread the damage is long-lasting
and this young man cannot even get the
treatment
because they say they won't fund it does
the prime minister feel no shame
that he
just totally trashed drills that he made
expected other people
to live with he wants to move on and
other people are left with the
consequences surely the prime minister
must resign
no mr speaker we want to get on with
addressing the kobe backlogs which is
what we're doing
hello thank you mr speaker
i sometimes wonder if the prime minister
has a neck of pure brass
does he understand and recognize the
words honesty integrity and
accountability
because from my position i don't think
he does
many members have spoken of personal
things and personal tragedies they've
gone through the country needs a new
leader yes we need to move on but we
shouldn't need to lead on with you prime
minister will you now resign
mr speaker i think that i'm just going
to repeat my my previous answer
debbie abrahams
you missed it mr speaker mr speaker the
prime minister's leadership his behavior
drives the culture in our politic
politics but also in our country and it
also gives licence to others to behave
in a similar matter so if he is genuine
in his apology and he's not
will he firstly ensure that the
ministerial and members codes have the
nolan principle principles incorporated
into them and put them on the statute
and secondly will he condemn
those old and conservative candidates
who delivered toxic racist misogynistic
leaflets during the recent local
elections his chairman has details of
that
i'd be i'd be very happy to look at uh
those details that she'll send them to
me
carol monahan
right let's pick somebody else done
jarvis
sir
that's the motto of the royal military
academy sanders and everybody
serving in our armed forces knows that
if the commanding officer of a unit had
presided over the kind of shambles we'd
seen in downing street they would be
discharged of their duties
why is it different from the prime
minister
[Music]
[Applause]
is he referring to the vaccine program
the ppe uh securing uh or or the fact
that we came out of covered parts of any
other european country yeah and okay
thank you mr speaker a comment that
sickened me from the sugary report was
and i quote i was made aware of multiple
examples of a lack of respect and poor
treatment of security in cleaning staff
the prime minister has made a public
apology at the dispatch box but when
will he personally apologize to those
hard-working cleaning staff who risked
every day
to ensure that everyone was kept safe
yeah i i thank you very much and just to
to repeat what i said uh both both
earlier on and to the honourable lady
opposite uh when i've identified the
custodians the cleaners the staffing
question of course i will uh talk to
them uh myself
dr rupa thank you mr speaker one address
20 months 204 questionnaires 345
documents 510 photos including the ones
on page 38 onwards of him raising a
toast when he should be toast
and as a result of this 126 fines mostly
to 83 junior staffers while all the
while
the police were routinely finding people
greater amounts than his 50 quid for far
lesser offences doesn't this all point
to a conclusion that
not everyone is as equal under the law
as each other these days
i i i think that there's a criticism of
the metropolitan police containing what
she's just said uh which i i don't agree
with
currency
the problem with this report mr speaker
is the dates outlined so clearly reopen
many of our wounds but i'm going to ask
the prime minister a question that has
been asked earlier that he didn't answer
from the member for newcastle underlying
when he met with sue gray recently this
week did he ask her not to publish this
report
no mr speaker and what i can tell the
honourable lady is that this is a a
wholly independent report and the the
judgments contained in it are a matter
for sue i'm sue gray i'm grateful to her
i'm grateful to her for what she has
done and i and i believe that uh it has
been extremely i think her interim
report was extremely useful uh to the to
the government in making the changes uh
that we have
the barbell
mr speaker when the years to come when
the prime minister reflects on his time
as pm and in government what does he
think will be his proudest moment
will it be breaking his own lockdown
laws and being found will it be
misleading parliament or will it be
lying to the queen and presiding over
such a toxic environment that as
according to sugray's report staff in
his office had a lively party the night
before her husband's funeral
mr speaker i will uh
look back many years hence on uh on
from this period i think the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe wasn't half
bad
being being the first country anywhere
in the world mr speaker to put an
approved vaccine in anybody's arms
and to come out of come out of kobe
faster than any other european country
those are already very considerable
achievements to say nothing of
delivering uh brexit which i'm afraid
she would not have done and nor would
the party opposite mr speaker
mr speaker um
the prime minister was asked whether he
thought any other prime minister would
have allowed such rule breaking on their
watch well i was a senior civil servant
for two prime ministers uh gordon brown
and uh the honourable lady for
maidenhead and i can tell him when i was
a senior civil servant no such behavior
would have occurred
what is clear in in the su grey report
to me is
the number of comments of civil servants
who knew
they were doing something wrong they we
seem to have got away with it this is
somewhat of a comms risk
people shouldn't be walking around
waving bottles of wine in front of
cameras and it goes on they knew they
were doing something wrong did the prime
minister
at any stage at any of these events he
was at think he was doing something
wrong
no well i've tried to be clear with the
house about that and i by the way she
talks about serving previous prime
minister i thank her for her service but
i want to assure i've never thrown a
stapler at
yeah thank you much mr speaker his
utterances on partygate at that dispatch
box have proven to be the fantasy we all
knew they were elegant allegra stratton
resigned for merely joking about a party
she's more integrity in a little finger
than the prime minister could ever hope
of possession this challenge our prime
minister is without without shame
without credibility and without any hope
of ever winning another election so does
he agree that he will sacrifice anyone
or any institution including his own
party
to try and keep his ever awakening grip
on power yeah yeah yeah
mr speaker i i know why they want to
remove me from offensive because we're
going to get on a win the next election
and that's that's the reality
speaker maybe the prime minister could
help me um again
um
if no rules were broken
what on earth did martin reynolds mean
when he said we got away with it
referring of course to the boo bring
your own booze party on the 20th of may
what did he mean we got away with it
yeah
i i must be i i can't uh
uh give an exegesis of what's in the
report she can read the report for
herself
[Applause]
thank you very much mr speaker when the
prime minister says he's sorry we know
he's sorry for getting caught one of my
constituents louise was in hospital in
november 2020
a very early woman lay in the bed
next to her crying and begging for our
family
she asked louise to phone and ask them
why they hadn't come to see her the last
thing she said to louise was i won't be
here in the morning
she died
with a student nurse holding her hand
which haunts louise to this day
does the prime minister agree with
louise
when she when she says he's a liar and
must resign
another brother i i have every sympathy
for uh for louise and all those who who
have suffered uh but no i'm speaking for
the reasons i've given i don't agree
with what he just said stephen park
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
has presided over a culture of law
breaking entitlement and privilege in
dining street he cannot credit credibly
plead ignorance on that point
in this statement he has sought to try
to rationalize this by saying that the
staff in downstream were working long
pressurized hours battling covet
so what does he say to the thousands of
doctors
nurses
care workers the emergency emergency
services
cleaners security staff and indeed
silver servants up and down the country
who didn't have work
alcohol field work events parties or
leaving dues
mr speaker i simply say to them what
i've said uh since the pandemic began
which is i thank them from the bottom of
my heart
dave mckay
i previously asked the prime minister to
release the publicly funded photographs
of these incidents he declined because
of the police investigation
is there any conceivable reason mr
speaker by the full publicly funded
catalogue of these incidents should not
now be released so that the public can
see and judge for themselves
mr speaker the what i can tell him is
that uh to the best of my knowledge i
think the uh all the evidence has been
seen by by sue gray and by the uh by the
metropolitan police uh uh there may be
there may be issues about what else can
be uh released more generally but he has
i believe a representative though the
public has i think a representative uh
sample
of the images
five times on a five page report the
premise that indicates that he takes
responsibility
but in actual fact he hasn't not once
during the pandemic all mps asked our
constituents to adhere to the guidelines
to protect themselves their family their
friends their colleagues and the wider
community
prime minister what's the benefit of
hindsight do you believe you set a good
example one that you can look back with
pride
mr speaker where where i fell short and
where we fell short uh i apologize i
want to thank all colleagues who asked
uh their constituents to to follow the
guidelines and i think actually yes the
government can be very proud of a lot of
what we delivered during code
dr caroline johnson well thank you mr
speaker um i've waited for this report
and looking through this report it's
clear to me that the prime minister did
break the rules on one occasion when he
was surprised by a birthday greeting
during between meetings in the cabinet
room this is a real breach clear rule
breach but one for which he's apologized
and i accept his apology
it is also clear from this report that
there was other examples which he was
not present at and which he did not
break the rules out but which others did
that occurred repeatedly during um
during the period of the lockdown so i'd
like to ask the promised what has he
learned from this and how do the changes
that he's put in place at number 10 make
sure that such examples and the
attitudes that allow them to occur will
not persist now
very i thank her very much and i think
that uh
my honourable friend from from
litchfield are substantially the same uh
a question it's uh i think the lines of
uh command and responsibility in number
10 are now much sharper uh thanks to the
uh installation of a of a new second
permanent secretary with direct
responsibility for everybody uh in the
building it matters thank you mr speaker
the prime minister must see that people
parting until the small hours on a
regular basis at downing street
paints an awful picture to everybody
else who has followed the rules but i
want to ask him specifically about the
gathering in his flat on the 13th of
november 2020 which contrary to what he
said today hasn't been fully
investigated by sue gray can he confirm
for the record that everyone who was
there that evening was working and there
was no alcohol no music or anything else
that people might reasonably conclude
constituted a party
i'm grateful to him and uh i i i think i
answered this already i've got nothing
to add to what uh
uh seuss grey says in her report or what
the metropolitan uh police found in
their
if i know investigation the prime
minister would love for these incidents
to be swept under the carpet and for us
all to forget about it but the panorama
documentary and this su-grey report
shows that utterly inappropriate and
shameless behavior that took place at
number 10 during lockdowns and the prime
minister has said that he wants to
appreciate his officials
at number 10 and by doing this he had
parties that took place every friday at
4 p.m an open bar and excessive drinking
and this is a way in which he
appreciated his staff and the sue grey
report states the excessive consumption
of alcohol is not appropriate in a
professional workplace at any time to
take responsibility is to resign the
prime minister has said he's not going
to do this can he say what he's doing
now to appreciate his staff and
officials at number 10.
i think what we what we're already doing
mr speaker is is is shortening up the
the the management of number 10 making
it easier for
for staff to uh to complain to voice
their uh their their anxieties uh but um
you know i've just got to say uh mr
speaker that um we've got to get on with
the business of government and i know
that she wants to persist with this uh
with this subject but uh i want those
officials to focus on the priorities of
the people
speaker it's rumored the chancellor will
shortly finally be announcing some
further help for our struggling
constituents with the cost of living
crisis but we know how things work in
this government with its enormous team
of spin doctors has his government
deliberately held back the details of
that desperately needed help in order to
provide some cover for the damning
impact of this report
mr speaker
i like many in this country have lost
loved ones my constituents have lost
loved ones
hundreds of thousands
thousands of people have lost loved ones
and the longer this goes on the more
traumatizing their experience is i can
tell him that sitting through these
statements is very traumatizing for many
of us who've lost loved ones and our
constituents that is why we cannot go on
like this
can the prime minister now
do the decent thing do the honorable
thing
and accept responsibility
and step down so that we can all move on
and get on with our lives and make sure
that people who suffered so much are
protected and served properly
of course uh appreciate the the
suffering of those on whom whose perhaps
she she speaks but i i do believe it is
the duty of the government to get on uh
as fast as we can
with uh sorting out the priorities of
the people now
um can i thank sue gray for publication
of a report it's good to see the final
article we all recognize that there have
been there are many lessons to be
learned from the handling of the
pandemic
from all levels of government as a
report states can the prime minister
working alongside devolved
administrations give an indication as to
when he will be launching the public
inquiry on covert 19 that he promised
the general public have questions to ask
and answers must be given when will the
general public have their say
i thank him as he knows baroness hallett
has been uh heather hallett has been
appointed to the uh to head the inquiry
and uh
he can expect developments uh soon
mr speaker it is absolutely imperative
but the british public are told the
whole truth
everyone hopes that there have been no
reductions or changes to this report
indeed darwin street said its intention
was to publish the report in full in its
entirety
unchanged so can i ask the prime
minister did anyone in number 10
receive a copy of a report yesterday
and were any requests made for sections
to be removed or altered
and following requests specifically
were there any changes made to the
section relating to the governing in the
number 10 flood on the 30th of november
2020
i can tell him that i received the
uh report uh myself and i had not seen
it before until
shortly after 10 o'clock this morning
and i i on his second point about
about uh
knowing mr speaker on my the second
point about uh the um
events in on november the 13th i've i've
addressed that several times
yes
thank you mr speaker well now we know
that while the prime minister was happy
to let the bodies pile high outside
downing street
he was also happy to let the bottles
pile up high inside downing street we
also know that he's come to that
dispatch box and denied point blank that
events took place that we now know did
take place and which turned downing
street into the most notorious party
flat in central london
mr speaker
the prime minister is diminished in
domini's office and he speaks of
leadership but any leader should know
when it's time to go why won't the prime
minister go so that the country can move
on and move on as it needs to without
him in office
[Music]
i think what he's just said is unworthy
of the civil servant some of whom i'm
sad to say were fined who worked night
and day to minimize suffering and
minimize casualties uh during coaching
thank you mr speaker my constituent ruby
fuller lived by the motto live kindly
live loudly in pursuit of social justice
ruby died from cancer on the 20th of may
2020 as the bring your own booze party
was happening in downing street her
grandparents and her young friends had
to say goodbye to ruby by zoom
what does the prime minister have to say
to ruby's friends
young people
in my constituency who are listening him
to him today blame everybody but himself
and when will he accept that every
single day he remains in downing street
our politics is corroded further
mr speaker i repeat my uh
condolences to those who suffered from
uh covid uh to to those who couldn't get
the treatment uh that they needed during
the pandemic uh to to the family of ruby
who couldn't uh see her when she was
suffering from uh from from cancer and
all i can say now is that we want to get
on with our work uh which is to clear
the backlogs particularly uh for cancer
patients up and down the country
daisy cooper thank you mr speaker for
the bereaved families of justice of
bereaved families of covid
this report will unleash another cruel
wave of loss and grief and anger
so as a bare minimum will the prime
minister promise
that the interim findings of the covert
inquiry will be published before the
next general election
uh that is a matter for the chair
andrew
thank you
to those mps that have clearly gone for
their lunch can i advise them that the
prime minister's humble pie is off
but uh was the prime minister
at the party on the 18th of december
2020 the so-called wine and cheese
evening which lasted for five hours and
when and i quote red wine was spilled on
one wall and the event was crowded and
noisy after which a cleaner was forced
to clean this up was he at it at any
stage of the proceedings
i think you will find the answer to that
question in sue grey's report
thank you very
much the conclusion of the report states
mr speaker
mr speaker
in conclusion the report states that
miss gray found that some staff had
witnessed and been subjected to
behaviors at work that are concerning
multiple examples of a lack of respect
and pro-treatment of security and
cleaning staff for me that is the most
damning but also the most telling part
of the report prime minister why is it
that people like him and the people at
work at number 10 think that cleaners
security guards nurses teachers are
beneath them less important than them
why mr president
mr speaker i condemn such behavior and
actually
when i was uh running london uh
transport for instance uh i instituted
much tougher penalties uh for those who
abused uh our staff and
and i i support tougher penalties for
those who abuse uh shop workers mr
speaker and those are the values i stand
for yeah
christian wakeford thank you mr speaker
wine time friday
karaoke grown men drinking shots of
apple salad how can anyone on the
bench's opposite honestly describe these
as work events
misleading the house is a very serious
issue as for prime minister well knows
but taking the people of this country
for fools is far worse
and whilst he's busy trying to defend
the indefensible i'd like to know mr
speaker
how many of my former colleagues does he
think will be joining me on these
benches after today
[Applause]
mr speaker
the
uh honorable gentleman
will find the answers to these questions
uh in the sugar report i i really don't
have anything more to add
dave dugan thank you mr speaker by the
actions of this prime minister standards
of public life in the uk now lie face
down in the gutter the prime minister
wants us all to move on collectively
well let me assure this derailed prime
minister there is no collective in
scotland of which you are a part here
here so as his authority as his
authority lies festering in a steaming
pile of incredulity will he set out to
the people of scotland the productive
and positive role he will play with the
scottish government in allowing and
enacting a referendum on independence so
we can finally free ourselves of exactly
the type of behaviour you typify
mr speak i will continue to work
productively with the
the government in scotland as we did
throughout the the pandemic uh not least
in delivering uh the fastest vaccine
rollout in europe in furlough uh in the
furlough program and everything else
that we did together that shows that
we're stronger together
thank you mr speaker in response to the
uh question put by my honourable friend
the member for will south the prime
minister said that he had not had time
to apologize to the cleaning and
security staff is he telling this house
that sue gray and no official appraised
him of one of the eight conclusions of
this report prior to him coming to the
house today or are they simply just not
his priority
yes of course mr speaker since i since i
know i should say since i uh
saw the report this morning i haven't
had time uh to be able to identify the
custodians or the uh the cleaners in
question uh but as i said earlier on to
the honourable lady opposite as soon as
i can i will apologize for them in
person
christine johnny
much mr speaker
i have been inaudibly proud of the way
my constituents and people up and down
this country have dealt not just with
the pandemic but with the economic
crisis that they now face
none of that is reflected in the
shameful behavior we see in the report
earlier much earlier i see the prime
minister look at his watch um one of his
own
colleagues suggested that perhaps we
should want to turn the page on what has
happened and believe me i think
everybody in this place would like to
turn the page and never have to revisit
again but the only way that we can do
that
is if the prime minister
accepts responsibility
fully
and moves on so we can't on that page
because i am going to move on uh with
the government's agenda and that's
exactly right
flynn
mr speaker i appreciate that the prime
minister struggles with the truth but
can he vouch to me and to this house
that he will do everything that he
possibly can to stave off his back
ventures and instead lead the campaign
to protect his precious union yeah
[Music]
i listen mr speaker i think increasingly
the strongest advocates of the uh of the
union of the united kingdom are the
scottish nationalist party uh who by
their incompetence uh they're over
taxing uh
their poor educational uh uh results
they can't even make the trains run on
time mr speaker they can't even buy uh
some some uh some ferries uh it uh
without without totally screwing it up
mr speaker uh they are the they are
terrific advocates of the united kingdom
and i thank them for what they're doing
order
order thank you
presentation of bill
presentation of bill secretary george
husters
you're watching sky news uh events
wrapping up in the house of commons i am
live at downing street this afternoon
after the publication of sugray's
damning final report into those lockdown
parties
is published it includes as we've been
hearing descriptions and photos of
parties many of which the senior civil
servant says should not have been
allowed to happen also contained in that
report pictures of the prime minister
drinking at events and details of others
involved in excessive drinking and
details of what has been described as a
minor altercation
well the prime minister has come under
fire from mps on both sides of the house
of commons this afternoon but he has
defended his position saying that he
takes full responsibility for what
happened well let's remind you of some
of what has been published by sue grey
today details of what took place of the
notorious bring your own booze party
organised by the prime minister's then
principal private secretary martin
reynolds the report says concerns were
raised that it wasn't a good idea but
afterwards reynolds wrote we seem to
have got away with it
sue gray also investigated a party that
took place in the cabinet office on the
18th of june 2020. there she found
excessive alcohol consumption by some
individuals
one individual was sick and there was a
minor altercation between two other
individuals
photos of a gathering for the prime
minister's 56th birthday in june 2020
are published in the report the report
saying food alcohol and soft drinks were
provided haven't been organized in
advance neither the pm nor the
chancellor were aware that the event was
being planned but both were fined by the
metropolitan police for attending
the prime minister told the house of
commons that he briefly attended downing
street lockdown gatherings but didn't
know at the time that they went on far
longer than was necessary in response
labour leader sikes dama accused mr
johnson of showing utter contempt for
the public and that this report
demonstrated the hubris and arrogance of
the government
i came to this house and said in all
sincerity that the rules and guidance
have been followed
at all times it was what i believed to
be true
it was certainly the case
when i was present at gatherings to wish
staff
farewell
and the house will note that my
attendance at these moments
brief as it was
has not been found to be outside the
rules
but clearly this was not the case for
some of those gatherings after i have
left
and at other gatherings when i was not
even in the building
so i would like to correct
i would like to correct
the record
to take this opportunity
not in any sense to absolve myself of
responsibility
which i take and have always taken
but simply
simply to explain
why i spoke as i did in this house
mr speaker
in response to her interim
report sue grey acknowledges that very
significant changes have already been
enacted
she writes
and i quote
i am pleased that progress is being made
in addressing the issues i raised
and she adds
since my update there have been changes
to the organization and management of
downing street in the cabinet office
with the aim of creating clearer lines
of leadership and accountability
and now these need the chance and time
to bed in
the entire senior management has changed
there is a new
there is a new
there is a new chief of staff
an elected member of this house who also
commands the status of a cabinet
minister
there is a new director of
communications a new principal private
secretary
and another of other key appointments
in
my office
i am confident with the
changes and new structures
that are now in place
that we are humbled
by the experience
and we have learned our lesson
and i want to conclude
by saying that
i mr speaker i i'm humbled and i have
learned a lesson
even now after 126 fines
they think it's everyone else's fault
but theirs
they expect others to take the blame
whilst they cling on
they pretend that the prime minister's
somehow been exonerated
as if the fact that he only broke the
law once is worthy of praise
the truth is
they set the bar for his conduct lower
than a snake's belly
and now they expect the rest of us to
congratulate him as he stumbles over it
number 10 symbolizes the principles of
public life in this country selflessness
integrity objectivity accountability
openness
honesty
leadership
but who could read this report and
honestly believe the prime minister has
upheld those standards
the reason the british public have had
to endure this pass was his refusal to
admit the truth
or do the decent thing when he was found
to have broken the law
this report was necessary
because of what sue grey describes as
failures of leadership and judgment
for which senior political leadership
must bear responsibility
it is that failure of leadership that
has now left his government paralyzed
in the middle of a cost of living crisis
the former justice secretary sir robert
buckland pressed the prime minister on
whether he had lied to parliament
my right honourable friend well knows
the rules apply to him as much to all of
us
and the rules of this house are clear
that anybody who comes here and
deliberately lies and misleads this
house should leave their position resign
or apologize
my right honourable friend has been
asked many times about specific
incident specific events that sue grey
has outlined
has he on any occasion
come to this house in response to
specific questions about specific events
and deliberately lied to us
no mr speaker for the reason for the
reason i have given that
at the time that i uh spoke to this
house i believe that what i was uh was
doing was was to attend work events and
uh with the exception of the event in
the in the cabinet room uh that is a a
view that has been vindicated uh by the
investigation
the former conservative minister to
myself
he was heckled as he asked how long the
party would defend what happened
this is a
damning report about the absence of
leadership focus and discipline in
number 10 the one place where you expect
to find those attributes in abundance
i made my point and my position very
clear to the prime minister he does not
have my support but a question i humbly
put to my colleagues is are you willing
day in and day out to defend this
behavior publicly
can we continue to govern without
distraction given the erosion of the
trust with the british people and can we
win the general election on this current
trajectory the question i place to the
prime ministers now
mr speaker i'm being heckled by my own
people if we cannot work out what we're
going to do
then the broad church of the
conservative party will lose the next
general election
but my question to the prime minister is
very clear on the question of leadership
can he think of any other prime minister
who'd have allowed such a culture of in
discipline to take place under their
watch and if it did
would they not have resigned
mr speaker i think to answer the
question that he put to uh all of us on
these benches i think the answer is
overwhelm overwhelmingly and
emphatically yes uh we are going to go
on uh win the next general election
because we're going to get on with the
job mr speaker
[Music]
from the opposite side of the house the
labour mp chris bryant was scathing
about the way security staff were
treated after they raised concerns about
the gatherings
what a load of baloney excuse after
excuse after excuse and it simply
doesn't wash and it won't wash with the
british public who are sick and tired of
being taken for fools the truth is the
prime minister encouraged the gatherings
he attended the gatherings he poured the
drinks at the gatherings and he even
raised the toast at the gathering so he
knew perfectly well that these
gatherings had taken place and the most
despicable thing of all
is that sue gray says
she saw multiple examples of a lack of
respect and poor treatment of security
and cleaning staff because they knew
what the rules meant even if nobody else
does
does he show no contrition no sense of
shame
that downing street under him has been a
cesspit full of arrogant entitled
narcissists
[Applause]
[Music]
mr speaker as i've said
to the house already i think that it is
absolutely disgraceful in any
circumstances uh to be rude uh to people
uh who are helping you and rude
to staff rude to custodians it's
intolerable uh and i will make sure that
uh those who are guilty of it uh
apologize or otherwise discipline
there was some support for the prime
minister from his own side and
conservative mps who agreed with boris
johnson that it was time to move on
when i think of civil servants and
advisors during that period i think of
the brilliant civil servants
who helped move mountains to create the
shielding program within a matter of
days i think of the brilliant civil
servants and advisors that got 90 of
homeless people off the streets within
days would my right or friend agree with
me that these achievements and others
should mean that nothing in this report
is a stain upon the character of the
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of civil servants whether in number 10
other government departments or across
the country who helped steer this
country through the pandemic and
secondly
difficult though this is to say for many
with a a war in europe
with an economic crisis
with the challenges this country faces
is it not really true
that it is now time to turn a page
and for this country
our politics and this house to move
forward
i agree with him absolutely uh
passionately mr speaker i think the best
thing uh i think we can study the uh the
report we can draw the conclusions that
we want the best thing now for our
country is to move forwards together and
that's what we're going to do
uh well just a flavor there of some of
the reaction to the sugray report in the
house of commons earlier on this
afternoon we could take a closer look
now at some of the detail in that report
let's bring in our deputy political
editor sam coats who's been studying it
in full since it was published earlier
on and sam what are your key takeaways
from sue grey's report
good afternoon afternoon sarah jane 37
pages taking us all the way from may
2020 to april 2021 sue grey trot through
a whole series of different events that
led to more than 80 people at the heart
of power being fined including the prime
minister and the chancellor she paints a
picture and draws her conclusions what
are the main takeaways so number one she
tells us that there was an unusual an
extraordinary culture of drunkenness at
the very top of government i'm going to
whiz you through a number of events
where she helps us to that conclusion
look at this this 18th of june this was
a leaving do uh for a cabinet office
official she talks about um how this
party which was attended by the cabinet
secretary in the deputy cabinet
secretary and the ethics advisor brought
her own karaoke machine she says the
event lasted for a number of hours there
was excessive alcohol consumption by
some individuals one individual was sick
there was a minor altercation between
two other individuals so there was a
fight at the heart of power so that was
in june now let's fast forward to
december three different parties on one
day two of them in downing street let's
see what sugray found out about that
some people working elsewhere in number
10 in the building that evening heard
significant levels of noise coming from
what they characterized as a party in
the press office a cleaner who attended
the room in the next morning noted that
there had been red wines filled on a
wall and on a number of boxes of
photocopier paper but one of the
extraordinary things about the report is
he discovered that as time went on the
behavior got worse look at this this is
about jane slack the former director of
communications leaving do and that was
uh in april 2021. let's look at some of
the details she highlights a number of
individuals gathered near a child's
swing now that's wilf the prime
minister's sons uh swing and slide in
the garden damaging on it by leaning uh
by damaging it by leaning on it and
playing with it this was noticed the
next morning and reported
the number 10 staff and look uh exactly
how late this leaving do uh ended up
being some individuals remained in the
building and carried on drinking alcohol
until the early hours exit loss because
they looked at the in
the indicators uh when people swiped in
and out indicate some left after
midnight others up till 2 45 two members
of staff stayed later still with one
leaving at 3 11 in the morning and the
last leaving at
4 20. the next big conclusion that she
helps us to is the fact that they knew
that there was rule breaking involved
because they were discussing the fact
that it broke the rules so let's look at
the lead up to the 20th of may 2020
bring your own booze party and look at
this lee kane another director of
communications boris johnson got through
a few uh says in an email to the most
senior official in number 10 martin
reynolds we'll hear about him again uh
in a moment i'm sure he'll be fine i
applaud the gesture but a 200 odd person
invitation for drinks in the garden of
number 10 is somewhat of a comms risk
communications risk of pr risk in the
current uh environment so he's there uh
quite clearly warning now that event uh
those warnings were ignored uh 34 to 40
people ended up in the garden with the
prime minister and he was there for
about half an hour and look after the
event martin reynolds that most senior
uh official in number 10 uh texted a
special adviser who was saying the media
are on to a different party story and
said that that story is a complete
non-story but better than them focusing
on our drinks which we seem to have got
away with
and you can just see if you just uh
flick across this report lots of
discussion between lee kane and martin
reynolds so advisors and officials
about whether who's going to take the
risk who's going to take the decision
who's going to get the blame and look at
this uh two unnamed officials ahead of
one event talking about when are we
having drinks which aren't drinks what
time are we planning on the drink so
they're quite clear i think that they
knew that what they were doing was at
least
strain the rules if not in breach the
third big thing finally third big thing
about this report is what it tells us
about the prime minister and it helps us
in this regard by printing some of the
photos so this is a photo of the prime
minister's birthday the prime minister's
birthday party and what it does is it
reminds us that boris johnson was fine
for being at this event which was at uh
for 20 minutes not night the nine
minutes the downing street uh cool um
said he was but here's simon case now
the most senior official uh in the whole
of whitehall he wasn't fined apparently
doing uh very much similar things uh to
what the prime minister was but he
appears to have got away with it so
pressure on the police to explain some
of their uh judgments another awkward
photo for the prime minister is this one
it's a similar one to the one we saw uh
on monday it is another director of
communication lee kane's leaving to here
you have the prime minister raising a
grass huge amount of alcohol on the
table that looks like uh a vodka bottle
there and uh clearly some fairly
cheapish white wine the prime minister
raising a glass to say goodbye what was
the judgment the thinking behind the
police when they decided uh not to find
the prime minister uh for that
but the third a really important bit of
what it concludes uh about what sugray
concludes about the prime minister
relates to this potentially the most
damaging moment for boris johnson was um
what happened in his private flat was
there a party in his private flat
after the departure of lee kane and
dominic cummings factions who didn't
like them celebrating the prime
minister's personal residence and what
sue grey was going to conclude about
that was going to be incredibly
important
here it says uh sue grey comes to her
determination on that following the
announcement uh uh she starts to tell
you what happened uh a number of people
went up to the flat after six o'clock uh
the prime minister was there from eight
food and alcohol were available the
discussion carried on later into the
evening and with attendees leaving at
various points aha was that a party you
ask also gray says that she's not going
to tell us why well the metropolitan
police then after she'd done some
investigating got involved and started
saying that they were going to look at
that event the metropolitan police
decided that they weren't going to issue
any fines for what happened there and
sue gray says following the metropolitan
police announcement on the night of the
mate 32 i considered whether or not to
conduct any further investigations in
this event but concluded it would not be
uh proportionate or appropriate to do so
so what are sugray's conclusions she
says the senior leadership at the center
both political and official must bear
responsibility for the culture of
drunkenness that she found in her report
but that doesn't mean that she's calling
uh for immediate action because she then
goes on to say i am pleased with the
progress that's been made in addressing
the issues that she raised in january
about this since my update there have
been changes to the organization and
management of downing street and the
cabinet office with the aim of creating
clearer lines of leadership and
accountability in other words the
leadership's responsible but there have
been changes and she's not suggesting
immediate uh an immediate different uh
approach so that actually gets both
boris johnson and simon case the head of
the civil service largely uh off the
hook uh in that section she does call
for junior people not to receive
excessive punishment and she does seem
to say that the culture in downing
street in the top of whitehall was out
of line with the culture elsewhere
in government departments it is my firm
belief however that these events did not
reflect the prevailing culture in
government and the civil service at this
time but it is not clear sarah jane
exactly what changes
flow from this report and what
consequences boris johnson uh must face
for she does not spell anything specific
out
sam thank you very much multitasking
here at sky news is sam is bringing us
the details of the report the prime
minister arrived back here at downing
street after answering questions in the
house of commons about the sue grey
report of course uh published earlier on
myself and a number of journalists here
asked if he was going to resign
he didn't answer went straight into
number two